okay next in our coverage of the Trump
Russia investigation I want to talk
about Roger stone Roger stone is was a
close Trump advisor he was a guest on
this program previously you can check
out my interview with Roger stone in our
archives Roger stone has announced that
he is pleading the fifth in the Trump
Russia probe in the context of the
Senate Judiciary Committee so remember
Donald Trump previously said not once
not twice but many times that you only
plead the fifth if you're guilty Roger
stone is indeed invoking his Fifth
Amendment privilege against
self-incrimination he's not going to
share documents he's not going to give
testimony to and with the Senate
Judiciary Committee based on a letter
that his attorney sent to Senator Dianne
Feinstein yesterday to catch everybody
up so we're all operating with the same
information what is the fifth amendment
the fifth amendment protects people from
being forced to be witnesses against
themselves in criminal cases so when we
say someone has pleaded the fifth
we're colloquially saying they're
invoking a right not to participate in
terms of asking answering questions and
it's a debate as to whether it applies
to providing documents when the
questions you answer or the documents
you provide might incriminate you it's
sort of like saying you don't have to do
prosecutors jobs for them they need to
build the case against you possibly
without your help and in the letter that
Grant Smith stones attorney wrote to
Dianne Feinstein he said mr. stone
respectfully declines to produce any
documents and declines the invitation
for an interview so hold on a second
let's go back to trump for a moment what
does Donald Trump said about pleading
the fifth I feel like Trump has
commented about this before oh well we
have this thing called audio and video
recordings let's look together at what
Donald Trump previously said about
people pleading the fifth take in the
fifth
I think it's disgraceful fifth amendment
Wow
the mob takes if it if you're innocent
why you taking the Fifth Amendment Fifth
Amendment horrible horrible he pleaded
the fifth and that was the end we never
heard about him again this is like
Watergate only it's worse in a sense
Trump is kind of right Roger stone is
very mob like more or less stone is a
sort of mob but it's tougher it's tough
to say it any clearer more clearly than
that so so to be clear I have no problem
with people invoking their Fifth
Amendment right it's constitutionally
given and provided and it sometimes
protects innocent people it sometimes
could conceivably protect guilty people
I don't have a problem with the Fifth
Amendment in principle in this
particular case it's interesting because
number one it's something that Donald
Trump slams people for and yet here he's
been teasing to Roger stone on Twitter
that it's really good for people to
simply refuse to cooperate
number two the Michael Flynn sentencing
memo
which we spoke about at the top of the
show confirms that this investigation is
not merely a witch hunt by Muller
looking to trick people into admitting
to crimes Flynn cooperated fully and
Muller recommended zero to six months in
prison that stone is refusing to
cooperate with Muller and refusing to
cooperate with the Senate Judiciary is
an indication that if Roger stone tells
the truth Pat that that would
incriminate him and that sort of seems
obvious at this point yeah we've covered
a similar story when Michael Flynn pled
the fifth initially and that didn't end
up going too too well for him because he
eventually was kind of forced into
cooperating with Muller I do think Roger
stone is one of those mob types that
Trump points out one of those people who
has guts like I don't foresee him
cooperating even if he is threatened
with a maximum prison sentence I just
don't know if that's in his character
yeah and to be clear we're talking here
about Roger stone pleading the fifth to
the Senate Judiciary Committee there's
every indication that Robert Moeller
already has enough evidence to indict
Roger stone and potentially send him to
prison for a long
so I'm not advocating for or against the
use of the fifth amendment the fifth as
I said it can protect people who are
guilty it can protect people who are
innocent it's a tool to make the legal
system do its job rather than to force
people to do the legal systems job for
it
it's the hypocrisy folks and I want to
hear from you about it what do you think
the sentencing memo for Michael Flynn
means what do you think stone pleading
the fifth means in the broader scope of
this investigation the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show
I'm also on Twitter where stefan
molyneux has been slamming me for the
last 12 hours at D Pakman I'll tell you
about that a little bit later on in the
show one of today's sponsors is
Skillshare which is an incredible online
learning community offering over 10,000
high-quality online courses on a huge
variety of topics first 500 who click
the link under this video will get two
entire months of totally free access to
every single class that Skillshare
offers you'll have free access to
courses on music art photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation and everything in between I
think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you just
took a really great class on graphic
design which I know nothing about but
I'm trying to learn our show is giving
you two entire months of totally free
access to every course Skillshare offers
risk free if you click the link under
this video you'll have two months to
take classes on anything you're
passionate about classes taught by real
people who share that passion and after
that you can keep getting access to the
entire site for less than 10 bucks a
month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry it's only available
to the first 500 who sign up